european gas prices again reached near
record highs on monday eu countries are
digesting the implications of russia's
decision to switch off flows down the
nordstrom one pipeline to germany
announced late on friday european stocks
dropped at the start of the week and the
euro has been trading at its lowest
value against the dollar for two decades
germany's chancellor schultz insists his
country can make it through the winter
without russian gas but europe will need
to reorganize its energy supplies
well for more on this let's speak to
maria demetz is deputy director of the
brussels based economic think tank
brugel thanks a lot for joining us on dw
business at this shutoff of the
nordstream one pipeline we knew it was
going to be shut off they said it was
just going to be for three days and then
it turned out it's indefinite but
it's not a surprise is it
oh no not at all it's not a surprise so
the the only thing is that so long as we
are not making a decision by we i mean
the european union we suffer
unpredictable consequences at the timing
where putin decides
uh uh to inflict pain um so you know we
have to find a way of changing and
controlling the message here uh for as
long as we don't decide uh putin then is
is capable of actually changing and
turning the tap off whenever he likes
so is what you're suggesting there that
it should be
a decision taken by the european union
to stop importing russian gas absolutely
absolutely
but what would the impact of that be i
mean there's a reason why that decision
hasn't happened so far it's that the eu
needs russian gas still
absolutely but we one way or the other
we're going to have to do without it and
we see it it happens
at the whims of of president putin what
what europe needs right now is to find a
way of reducing consumption of of all
energy because all energy would need to
be uh reduced and it needs to happen in
a way that is controlled coordinated and
co-organized this is what european
leaders will be working for this
september and early in october in the in
the following meetings that they have
the difference would be that we will
control that we will manage that for the
moment we are simply reacting and as we
are reacting so is the market and we are
seeing that the market prices are
jumping unexpectedly
in a way that is much more volatile than
had it been at our own decision
and of course the euro itself follows
because it reflects a market sentiment
so do you think that european leaders
are doing enough to try and prepare for
a winter without russian gas i mean
chancellor schultz seems to think that
germany is in a good position to get
through or at least to scrape through
well indeed if that is the case then we
should take the decision much faster
than this
there would there will not be any
solution without a reduction
of consumption the question is by whom
at what pace
until when
we know that next winter is going to be
a difficult winter because we have to
decouple from russian
energy oil will happen by the end of the
year and gas well probably will happen
sooner than that but it will not happen
but from us it will happen
when the russians decide to do it that
is not good for the prices because it
makes it much more volatile
had the european union come more
decisively and said we are cutting it
off immediately or at the very
predictable
time path then all markets will have
organized themselves accordingly and
therefore the price will be a lot more
controlled the supply is what it is we
cannot do anything about that but what
we can do is control the timetable of it
can we read anything into putin's
approach here of cutting off supplies to
europe in terms of what the impact of
the sanctions have actually been for
russia's economy is it worse than the
countries letting on
well i think the impact of the sanctions
given the decisions that we've taken on
the russian economy will only be in the
medium term or the long term let's be
clear about this it would be
catastrophic for the russian economy but
we're not going to see it this time this
uh winter probably for another six
months or so simply because we are still
relying on energy on russian energy and
that of course puts the price up
um and it only benefits the revenues for
the russian economy and so that is the
bit that i think we still need to fix we
have to cut it off bite the bullet
and forbid
the russian economy for benefiting from
the huge incremental prices we've seen
on on energy this is the issue that
needs to be resolved the supply side we
have to cut it but also let's be clear
that the russian economy is going to
bake an enormous hit uh but with some
delay
okay maria de meza's from brugel thank
you very much for joining us here on dw
business